so by far the most famous dimension
reduction approach is principal
components regression
and principal components regression
involves
a two-step procedure in step one we find
what are called principal components of
the data matrix x
and we're going to cover principal
components in in detail in chapter 10 of
the textbook and so i'm not going to
cover that in great detail here
so in step one we get principal
components and then in step two we're
just going to perform least squares
regression using those principal
components as predictors
so basically principal components are an
interesting idea and the first principal
component is just the linear combination
of the variables that has the highest
variance
the second principal component is the
linear combination that has the largest
variance
out of all linear combinations that are
totally unrelated to the linear
combination that we just got
and so on and so the principal
components give us linear combinations
or dimensions of the data that are
really high in variance and that are
uncorrelated to the ones that we
previously got
and so the idea is that if you give me a
data set with 35 variables
i can compute a few principal components
and those might capture most of the
variation in the data but in a very
succinct way involving just a few new
variables z1 through
z3 or z1 through z4
so here's an example of principal
components analysis on a very simple
data set that we saw in chapter three
already
and so what we're showing here is a plot
where the x-axis shows population and
the y-axis shows ad spending for a
hundred different cities
um and so those are those are these
purple dots and so this is a simple data
set with just p equals two variables
and so i can say all right what's the
what's the linear combination of these
variables that has the most variance or
equivalently what's the direction along
which this data varies the most
and so we can see that the direction in
which the data varies the most actually
falls along this green line this is
really the direction with variation in
the data and so that's actually the
first principal component direction
and then if we say hey what's the
direction along which the data varies
the most out of all directions that are
uncorrelated with that first direction
that's this blue dashed line here
and so that's the second principle
component in this data so in this
example p equals two and there's only
two principal components but in general
um in a data set with lots of variables
if p is large there's a lot of principal
components and we can look at the first
one or the second one or the third or
the fourth and so on
so um here's sort of a zoom in a little
bit on what's happening here and the
idea is in this on the left hand side
here we just have about 20 locations
shown as purple circles
and the reason that this green line here
is the first principal component is
because it's the direction along which
the data varies the most it's the line
such that um
that
the the points are the most spread out
possible along the line if i drop each
point
two oops
if i drop each of these locations
down to the line then this sum of square
distances is really as large as possible
and so all these little red lines
indicate the distance from a location to
the principal component line it's
actually small as possible right oops
yeah this is the um i misspoke this
green line is the principal component
it's the direction along which the data
varies the most and it's also the
direction along which the distances from
the purple points to the green line
which i'm showing in red is as small as
possible
and on the right hand side here i'm
really seeing the same picture again but
now it's been rotated um so that that
principal component line is um is
horizontal just to make it a little
easier to see
so if i want to understand these
principal components better i can
actually plot each principal component
so each linear combination of the
variables that i got
on the x-axis and i can plot it against
population
and against ad spending
and
what i can see is that the first
principal component is really highly
correlated with population and highly
correlated with ad spending
and so what that means is that i'm
really summarizing the data very well if
instead of using those original two
variables population and ad spending i
instead use just the first principal
component so that kind of suggests the
idea hey if i want to predict some
response
like sales
instead of using population and ad
spending to predict sales i can just use
the first principal component i can just
treat that as a predictor in a model fit
the model using least squares and i bet
those results are going to be pretty
good
um so now this figure is just like the
previous one
but instead of showing the first
principal component on the x-axis it's
showing the second principal component
against again population and ad spending
and we can see that there's very little
relationship between population and the
second principal component and between
ad spending and the second principal
component so that suggests that really
the first principal component here does
a great job of summarizing the data
and in this case that's happened because
population and ad spending are really
correlated with each other and so one
new variable which is the first
principal component can really summarize
both of those two variables very well
so the idea is
i i take my data i get the first couple
principal components as many as i want
and i use those as predictors in a
regression model that i fit using least
squares
and that can actually in a lot of
settings give really nice results
so here's an example on a simulated data
set
where i have
a bunch of observations
and i perform principal components
regression with with various numbers of
principal components
so like over here i have one principal
component
all the way through to around 45
principal components in this example
and so what i'm plotting here is the
bias shown in black oops
this is the bias
this is the variance in green and this
is the mean squared error
and so as i get more and more components
in my model as i use more and more
principal components
i'm going to get less and less bias
because i'm going to be fitting a more
and more complex model but i'm going to
pay a price in that my variance is going
to increase as the number of components
increases
and remember the mean squared error is
just the squared bias plus the variance
so my mean squared error which is shown
here in purple has sort of approximately
that u shape that we've been talking
about
and i can see that my mean squared error
is really smallest
for a model with around 18 principal
components
so um so using principal components
regression with 18 predictors works
really well here
in this example over here the
situation's a little bit different now
my mean squared error once again
decreases as i add more components but
it doesn't really increase again it's
pretty flat from around here outwards
so any of these models looks around the
same in terms of chest mean squared
error and since i always prefer the
simplest model possible
in this context i might choose maybe
this model with around 25 components
so the idea is to summarize the right
summarize the features by the principal
components which are the the
combinations with highest variance right
um i guess why is that a good idea or
why is it could it be a bad idea
yeah so that's a good question and one
thing that we notice here is that when i
compute those principal components i'm
not actually
looking at the response i'm literally
just looking at my predictors my x's
and i'm looking for a linear combination
of them that has high variance
and
it's kind of making this assumption that
a linear combination of the predictors
that has high variance is probably going
to be associated with the response
and that's kind of a hunch that we often
have as statisticians it's an assumption
that we often make but really there's no
reason that that has to be the case and
in fact it might not be well so let me
just draw a picture to talk about that a
bit more looking for some space okay so
if we think of our
we have a plot here but with this let's
say there's two variables right and
here's my scatter plot of points and the
first principle components direction
is going to be
along this
let's move in on this red line right
that's the first principal component so
as daniella said if we summarize these
two variables by the principal component
we're really assuming that this
direction of variation is the important
one so we think of y coming out out of
the slide we're really assuming that the
regression plane varies
along the red line and doesn't vary in
the orthogonal direction right because
we choose one component we're going to
ignore the second direction
is that a good assumption well it's not
always going to be the case but it's it
tends to be quite reasonable because one
way to think about it is if this is this
is observational data the fact that
we've measured the variables at all
probably means that they could be
they're likely to be important right we
we measure things in experiment to
predict something i think the things we
measure we're more likely to measure
things which are important so the
things that matter are probably going to
vary in the direction of the response
not always but it's a good it's a good
hunch that all else equal let's look uh
in the direction of variation of the
predictors to find the the places where
the response is most likely to vary
okay so let's go back to
where we're talking about the number of
directions okay
yeah so when we perform principal
components regression um we need to
somehow
select the number of directions m and we
just saw that um
you know the the test mean squared error
um we want it to be as small as possible
so we've got to estimate the test mean
squared error and by now you've probably
seen that rob and i really prefer
cross-validation over any other approach
so we would select
we would suggest using using cross
validation in order to choose the number
of principal component directions that
you want to use
um so here that's what we did on the
credit data
um so on the the x on the left hand side
we can just see the results of just
performing just plain principle
components regression on the data so
like for instance
if we want to look at the principal
components regression model with six
principal components so m equals six
um that's this blue line and so we can
see that like you know three a few of
these coefficients are non-zero and then
a few others are basically zero
over here we've got 11 components
and that's actually the full least
squares model because when m equals p
you've just got regular least squares on
the original data
and we can on the right hand side see
for each of those same models we can see
the cross-validated mean squared error
so this is an estimate of the test error
and here we actually see something
that's pretty disappointing remember we
we like to pick a model for which the
mean squared error is as small as
possible
and so here the mean squared error is
really as small as possible when we have
a model with 10 or 11 components
and remember when m equals 11 that is
just going to be
regular least squares on the original
data
so basically principal components
regression just tells us to when you
choose the number of components by
cross validation on this particular data
set it tells us to just forget it and
just do least squares on the original
data
so this is
this is sort of disappointing it means
the principal components regression
doesn't give us any gains over just
plain least squares that you guys saw in
chapter three
but this is also something that happens
in a lot of contexts you can try to beat
least squares but it might not work on a
particular data set
so as rob mentioned with principal
component regression we're just coming
up with these new transformed variables
which were the principal components
um just in a totally unsupervised way
we're just looking at the x variables
and we're just going to cross our
fingers that the directions on which the
x variables really vary a lot are the
same directions in which
the variables are correlated with with
the response y
um but if we don't want to just have to
keep our fingers crossed and hope for
the best we can instead perform what's
called partial least squares
and partial least squares is just like
principal components regression but it
selects these these new predictors z1
through zm
in a supervised way
um it's going to choose z1 through zm
that are linear combinations of the
original features that are directions
along which the original features vary a
lot
but there are also directions that are
related to y
so instead of just looking for a
direction on which x varies we're going
to look for a direction on which x
varies
that also has to be related to the
response
and so the goal here is to to be able to
more effectively predict the response
because we explicitly think about the
response when we're choosing these new
features c1 through zm
so the idea behind partial least squares
is um
is we get the first direction of partial
least squares
by doing a regression of y onto x1 that
gives us phi 1 1.
we do a regression of y on to x2 that
gives us v12 and so on until we do a
regression of y onto xp and that gives
us v1p
and so in fact the first principal
component direction z1 the first
partially squares direction that we get
z1 is really proportional to the
correlation between y and the data
matrix x
so that's how we get c1 and then we get
the other partial least squares
directions just by sort of iterating
this procedure
and so in principle partial least
squares seems like it should be a huge
gain over principal components
regression because we're choosing those
z's in such a clever way that actually
involves looking at the response which
seems like it can only help us
but in practice
um we have found that partial least
squares often does not give us a huge
gain over principal components
regression it's very similar to ridge
regression and p and pcr component
regression so although some people do
like partially squares i i've never
found it very useful and found that
ridge and
prince components regression is
work as well and is simpler both simpler
and actually one thing that's
interesting is rob mentioned ridge
regression and and it might seem like
you know going back ridge regression is
really different from principal
components regression and partial least
squares but it turns out that
mathematically these ideas are all very
closely related and um
and prince
principal components regression for
example is kind of just a discrete
version
of ridge regression ridge regression is
kind of continuously shrinking variables
whereas
principal components is doing it in a
more choppy sort of way exactly
so we've covered a lot today
and
now you've seen a lot of different model
selection methods
which are really useful in settings
where you might have a lot of
observations but you have a lot of
variables so you know if if someone
comes to you with some data with a
million observations and four variables
then do least squares knock yourself out
or even use some of the approaches that
you're going to see in chapters 7 8 and
9 which are even more flexible and more
complex alternatives to least squares
but if someone comes to you with data
with you know 400 observations and 300
variables or even 30 000 variables
you're going to need ways to simplify
the problem and to fit really simple
models that are even simpler than what
least squares is going to give you and
those are really some of the ideas that
we covered today
so um this is this is a really exciting
topic and a lot of modern statistical
research really focuses on how we can
improve prediction in settings like the
ones we covered today where we just want
a simple model that's simpler than least
squares because the
least squares fit is really going to
overfit the data